let's go next to Kelly who is on the
line in Florida
Kelly how could help hi I've been a
special education future can for 29
years
um I said to one of my colleagues couple
weeks ago I go can you believe next year
I'll have done this for 30 years Wow and
that's what I thought I thought wow no
but I'm saying wow in a good way that's
impressive yeah I don't say I'm really
proud of it you should be it's not yeah
it's not something I plan on leaving I I
don't want to leave my career I was
married to a marine for 28 years so I
got to travel and do a lot with that
what's happening now is though I said it
out loud that it's 30 years and I'm
really trying to think of a way to
increase my income but honor what I do
and use the knowledge that I've gained
for sure in this area over that much
time okay and how much do you make I'm a
57 it's 57 years with two masters
degrees right right right
and so I know you've been in special ed
but you just laid it out beautifully I
want to do something that honors what
I've been doing so in your mind what
have you wondered about what is a step
up or step two or three up from what
you've been doing now what would that
field look like or what would that role
be I really want to help more um my
audience right now are the kids that I
work with and the families that I work
with and it's a lovely audience was I
had what I wanted though I would want to
be able to reach more people and so many
people don't understand what their
children really need so many educators
are confused and want to do well but
don't always understand what's required
okay all right this is fun okay I'm
starting to track all right now it's
time for you to dream and you have to
promise me before you answer this next
question that you're not going to come
up with limitations you're just going to
let your heart
throw it out there do you promise yeah
alright if you knew you couldn't fail
okay you absolutely knew it wouldn't
fail
how would you affect more people knowing
what you already know right now how
would you get that information out to
them I honestly I have really thought
about and even have started kind of
working on a blog website um to look at
you know what what am i reading now what
can you learn from it what what is a
great resource for assistive technology
and who can I help yeah see here's the
here's the question you really do know
where to look even if you don't know the
exact resource that a family or you know
someone affected has a special needs
person in their family whatever it is
that you just know the direction even if
you don't have the resource you could go
find it couldn't you oh okay that makes
you tremendously valuable so let me
throw something at you here's what I
want you to consider Kelly I want you to
consider launching the blog tonight but
why not do it on a Facebook page don't
even worry about a design create a
facebook page you can do that it cost
you nothing and I want you to start
writing and I want you to commit over
the next week to write five or six
pieces okay coming out of your existing
experience something you're fired up
about second thing I want you do is
launch an Instagram page put some
resources out there then I want you to
start a podcast just record something
from your heart interview some people
that are experts right there in your
area I want you in short Kelly to begin
to create content that you know is
valuable that you know will help your
target audience see you're absolutely
clear you know who you want to help you
know what problem you want to solve you
know what solution you want to provide
start doing
and let's not try to do it full-time
right let's just do it on the side let's
build the platform build the audience
start going to the conventions and the
trade shows and getting online in the
webinars where other people who are
sourcing these families you start
hanging out all the time just use the
proximity principle get around people
that are doing what you want to do get
in places where what you want to do is
happening killing guess what
opportunities are going to present
themselves to you you've got what it
takes it's go time